immer wieder russische Angriffe aus der
Luft immer wieder häuten die sie reden
immer wieder mussten Menschen in
Schutzräume flüchten auch Olena selensky
die Frau des ukrainischen Präsidenten
die First Lady der Ukraine unter dem
Eindruck dieser feigen Angriffe gegen
Zivilisten führte unser Reporter Paul
ronsheimer der selbst alles hautnah
miterlebt hatte heute morgen ein
ausführliches Interview mit der
Präsidenten Gattin hier ist es in voller
Länge und exklusiv Mr silenska First
Lady
es ist eine große Ehre mit ihnen zu
sprechen an diesem schrecklichen Tag wir
sind um 6 Uhr morgens aufgewacht von
kamikazedonen wie sind sie heute
aufgewacht DAX
genauso wie sie
verstehen einander denn wir sind in der
gleichen Situation wie alle anderen
Ukraine ich bin heute um 6 Uhr 17 Uhr
aufgewacht der Bäcker war auf 6 30
gestellt
weil ich meinen Sohn für die Schule
fertig machen wollte
wie auch alle anderen musste ich
entscheiden was ich tun muss wir sind in
den Keller gegangen aber die Kinder
müssen etwas essen ich bin wieder nach
oben gegangen haben Frühstück
vorbereitet
später musste ich entscheiden ob der
Sohn zu in die Schule geht ich habe die
Schule angerufen sie sagten dass die
Eltern selbst entscheiden müssen ich
habe heute den Sohn zu Hause gelassen
fürs Online-Unterricht und bin selbst
zur Arbeit gefahren wir sind alle hier
in dem gleichen Situation und heute
hatten sie die Möglichkeit zu sehen was
geschieht sie können das Leben nicht
weiter als einige Minuten planen die
Planen trotzdem denn wir können das
Leben nicht auf später verschieben
das würde bedeuten dass wir dem Terror
nachgeben
die letzte Woche wie wir sie wissen was
genauso beginnen mit Montag waren alle
Pläne zerstört viele trafen mussten
abgesagt werden wir könnten die Pläne
nicht umsetzen und wir hoffen dass diese
Woche und nächste Woche werden wir
unsere Pläne weiter verfolgen
how was your sunright wie hat ihr Sohn
reagiert als er den raketenalarm hörte
alle Kinder
regieren relativ ruhig darauf vielleicht
ist es so schlimm aber die Kinder
gewöhnen sich und gewöhnen sich
schneller als die Erwachsenen heute als
wir darüber gesprochen haben ob er zur
Schule gehen soll er hat darauf
bestanden dass er in die Schule fahren
möchte ein Kind hat keine Angst in die
Schule zu gehen er weiß dass er dort
auch einen Schutzraum hat dort sind
seine Kinder seine Freunde und
Mitschüler er möchte
normales Leben führen und für
irgendetwas besser zur Schule zu gehen
als zu Hause
vor dem Laptop zu sitzen und am
Online-Unterricht teilzunehmen obwohl
das für mich vielleicht
besser ist wenn ich ihn bei mir habe die
Kinder verstehen alles nicht schlechter
als Erwachsenen
für Sie persönlich wenn sie so wie heute
aufwachen und Kamikaze Drohnen
explodieren sie müssen doch denken
vielleicht sind sie das Ziel oder Ihr
Haus der Präsidentenpalast ihre Familie
was denken Sie in solchen Momenten
natürlich sind wir
jetzt nicht dort dann die Adresse ist
für alle bekannt die ist bei Google Maps
eingetragen wir wohnen an einem anderen
Ort aber ich bin
nicht genauso wie alle anderen Ukraine
und ich weiß dass ich genauso eine
Zielscheibe sein kann wie auch alle
anderen es ist nah
denn wenn du aufwachst
durch einen Luftalarm dann kannst du dir
machen ist man du weißt was zu tun ist
und du versuchst nicht mehr nachzudenken
was passiert wenn es dich trifft jetzt
im Büro ist die Atmosphäre sehr drückend
dann sie wissen dass die Kamikaze
Drohnen ein Haus im Kiew zerstört hat
und
sind einige Menschen gestorben und eine
der Frauen die dort gestorben sind ist
eine schwangere Frau eine Bekannte von
meiner Mitarbeiterin sie waren wir waren
jetzt alle im Büro und haben das
zusammen mit ihr durchlebt es kommt
immer näher an dich heran letzten Montag
als Zentrum von hier wieder attackiert
wurde und sie wissen dass eine Rakete
die Kreuzung der volodemerska-straße und
die Straße daraus getroffen hat in einer
Rakete hat ein Kinderspielplatz
getroffen und auf diesem
Kinderspielplatz war ich oft mit meinen
Kindern
von der Kreuzung wurden die Scheiben
eingeschlagen
in einen der Gebäude von Shevchenko
Universität eine Bekannte von mir
arbeitet dort und sie hat mir dann ein
Foto geschrieben wie Sie und andere
dozentenden die Glasscherben aufräumen
das Spielplatz sind in anderen Gebäude
auch die Fenster schreiben
zersplittert es ist sehr nah an Dich
immer
eine junge Frau Oxana die an der
Kreuzung gestorben ist
sie arbeitete in dem Krankenhaus
achmedit am nächsten Tag habe ich mir
Interview ihrer Kolleginnen angeschaut
ihr Direktor Vorgesetzter Alexandra
lesitzer er ist der Leiter der
transportzentrums ich kenne ihn
persönlich wie
oft miteinander zu tun es kommt immer
näher zu Dir du kannst das nicht
ignorieren aber es ist keine Zeit
nachzudenken es ist Zeit zum Handeln
und das Handeln hilft dir du kannst
deine Pläne nicht nach hinten
verschieben du musst weitergehen
ich sehe jetzt nur time to reflect
it still zu reflektieren aber der Krieg
geht schon fast acht Monate wie
verändert der Krieg bei Ihnen die Liebe
das ist paradox
aber ich habe das Gefühl
dann in diese schrecklichen Zeiten
brauchen wir die Liebe noch mehr die
Leber wird offensichtlicher
widersprüchliche Informationen
vielleicht
die Zahl der Eheschließungen in Ukraine
ist um 20% gestiegen die Menschen
verstehen in diesen Bedingungen was für
dich das Wichtigste ist sie wollen die
leberserklärungen nicht auf später
verschieben sie wollen das schaffen den
liebsten Menschen über ihre Gefühle zu
sprechen
dass dieses Jahr ein Rekordjahr ist was
die Anzahl der Eheschließungen
in den letzten sieben Jahren
ihr Leben verändert ihr Familienleben
und ihr Leben mit dem Präsidenten
und ja the life with the president
wir arbeiten vielen Familien in der
Ukraine
die meisten Familien sind getrennt
im Alltag können wir uns nicht oft sehen
natürlich kann ich in ab und zu hier im
Büro treffen
ich kann es aber nicht über unsere
Kinder sagen
wir treffen sind sehr selten und er
fehlt Kindern sehr wenn wir über Gefühle
sprechen
und ich denke wir brauchen einander noch
mehr
lassen Sie uns ein paar Monate
zurückgehen als der Krieg auch hier in
Kiew anfing als wir die ikonischen
Videos des Präsidenten sahen zur
gleichen Zeit sagt Experten weltweit das
Kiew innerhalb von Tagen umzingelt sein
könnte wie verängstigt waren sie damals
darüber das Kiew innerhalb von einigen
Tagen um ziegelt werden kann
wurde schon später gesprochen die
Atmosphäre war sehr drückend wir wussten
dass
große Gefahr über uns schwebt aber
damals habe ich das Gefühl
nicht dass Menschen nicht darüber
nachgedacht haben aber wir mussten
handeln wir mussten Ruhe bewahren
ich habe darüber auch nicht nachgedacht
wie hoch die Gefahr war
von Anfang an wusste ich dass er in Kiew
bleiben wird deshalb gab es keinen Sinn
darüber nachzudenken
ich habe versucht das zu tun was von mir
abhängig wie von einem Motor in Ruhe
bewahren die Kinder anzulegen ihnen das
Gefühl zu geben dass die Erwachsenen
sich um die Sicherheit kümmern und eure
Aufgabe liegt darin einfach auf die
Eltern zu hören schnell die Sachen zu
parken
wenn jemand sagt sie sollen essen dann
sollen sie essen
schlafen dann sollen wir schlafen
aber trotzdem gab es Berichte darüber
dass ihr Mann auf einer abschlussliste
steht das in die Russen töten wollten
und noch immer töten wollen das muss sie
doch beschäftigen es war damals und so
ist es geblieben wir wissen das
Bayern ein Land das sie gerade im Krieg
befindet die Leitung nicht mehr hat dann
wird
das Land in
ich versuche darüber nicht nachzudenken
und ich wiederhole noch einmal wir haben
keine Zeit um zu reflektieren
you can't think about it wie sie sagen
sie wollen nicht daran denken aber wenn
sie zurückblicken was war der Moment der
in dem Kopf geblieben ist von den ersten
Stunden von den ersten Tagen des Krieges
der Krieg hat nicht am 24 Februar
begonnen Betrieb hat im Jahr 2014
begonnen
die ganze Zeit in diesem Krieg aber die
Welt hat leider nicht so aktiv reagiert
wie heute
deshalb als diese
wahlumfängliche Aggression begonnen hat
war es natürlich ein Schock für alle
Menschen in der Welt
ich denke dass die Europäer und der
Amerikaner
genauso betroffen waren davon dass im 21
Jahrhundert jemanden in den Kopf kommt
so ein schreckliches Krieg zu beginnen
und danach
als sie alle gesehen und gefüllt haben
wen grauenhaft das Böse ist
als das Zivilbevölkerung zu Zielscheibe
geworden ist
da haben wir verstanden dass es nicht
einfach anderen Krieg geht es ist ein
terroristischer Angriff ein Krieg auf
Vernichtung dann Krieg hat Gesetze und
bis zu 24 Februar haben wir uns
vielleicht darauf innerlich vorbereitet
wir dachten vielleicht dass es nicht
logisch ist aber innerlich haben wir uns
darauf eingestellt doch niemand könnte
sich vorstellen
dass das so schrecklich sein wird
versuchen Sie jetzt jeden Moment
intensiver zu durchleben weil sie wissen
wie gefährlich ist
intensiv gut
es ist möglich jetzt
früher könnte ich mich ablenken oder
über
Alltägliches nachdenken oder mein Urlaub
planen oder etwas anders planen
etwas zu Hause
doch jetzt gibt es keinen Sinn darauf
die Zeit zu verschwenden
wir wissen dass wir in Pläne für heute
haben wir müssen heute handeln und ich
handelt
habe ich keine Zeit
umstehen zu bleiben um mich
herumzuschauen und nicht noch einmal
erschrecken darüber was geschieht ich
denke so ist das
Gesetz ich denke nicht dass wir uns zu
diesem Interview treffen würden wenn sie
kriegt nicht da wäre ob ich interessant
für sie wäre es gab weniger Interview
jetzt gibt es mehr Interview weil
ich nutze diese Möglichkeit um die Welt
über die Ukraine erzählen über Menschen
die hier leben
you talking about the interviews von
beginning of the war at the same time
sprechen über die Interviews vom Anfang
des Krieges gleichzeitig sind sie mehr
in die Öffentlichkeit gerutscht sie
haben ein Interview geführt ein
Fotoshooting mit der Vogue gemacht es
gab sehr viel Kritik daran es wurde
gesagt ein Shooting wenn ich das
richtige wie sehen Sie das
erstens wenn du ein Vorschlag bekommst
von work von einer Winter
dann muss dieser Vorschlag in Betracht
gezogen werden zweitens man es einen
Vorschlag gibt da eine Fotosession mit
any Label Hits durchzuführen
dann muss man auch es in Betracht ziehen
doch ehrlich gesagt natürlich habe ich
darüber nachgedacht
ich musste darüber nachdenken ich habe
auch abgewogen
beim Nachdenken wusste ich dass das
Publikum besteht aus 4 Millionen und ich
kann dieses Publikum erreichen wo es
schon lange nicht mehr die Zeitschrift
die sich nur mit fashion beschäftigt
eine Interview die gegeben habe es ging
nicht nur
um das öffentliche Leben es ging auch um
die soziale Probleme um die globalen
sozialen Probleme für mich war es
interessant dieses Interview zu geben
was ich zu dem Fotoshooting sagen kann
also habe ich mich auf die
Perspektive von Annie verlassen und ich
habe das Gefühl es ist uns stark
gelungen das einzige
wo du mich noch nachgedacht habe war das
Fotoshooting in hustomer neben unserer
Maria neben dem Traum und dann habe ich
begriffen es ist auch mein Traum meinem
Ria die die Besatzer zerstört haben und
ich habe das Recht dazu mich daneben zu
stellen und meine Gefühle zum Ausdruck
bringen
deshalb bereue ich es gar nicht dass wir
es getan haben und ich bin sicher dass
es uns noch mehr Kraft gegeben hat
einmal mehr Kraft verlieren hat in der
Zeit wo es nötig war als wir an der
Material gearbeitet haben
waren Stimme zu hören dass die Welt sich
an den Krieg gewöhnt hat dass die
Menschen
auf der Welt
müde sind
von den Informationen und deshalb
mussten wir andere Wege suchen
um nicht in Vergessenheit zu erreichen
andere Wege und ich habe das Gefühl es
ist
ungelungens still in Germany and
gleichzeitig gibt es Hunderttausende
Ukrainer die in Deutschland leben wann
können diese Ukraine wieder nach Hause
kommen oder ist es noch zu gefährlich
gerade heute in Kiew haben wir gesehen
was das bedeutet ich habe Menschen
gesprochen die geflohen sind dann im
Sommer wieder zurückkamen und die müssen
jetzt erleben das ist noch schlimmer
wird
natürlich können wir nicht erwarten dass
die Menschen zurückkommen bis die
Situation sicher genug ist und hier die
Luftverteidigung ist das erste was uns
Sicherheit gibt
die Menschen die jetzt in Deutschland
sind ich möchte dass die Menschen sich
würdig in ihrem Land fühlen damit Sie
die Möglichkeit haben zu arbeiten damit
die Kinder zur Schule gehen können
ich bin sicher das ist nicht für immer
ist wir möchten sehr
diese Belastung aushandeln und ich weiß
dass es für Menschen in Deutschland auch
schwierig ist diese wirtschaftliche
Belastung ist sehr hoch die Belastung
gab die Gesellschaft
aber wir müssen alle geduldig sein und
auch sicherer Zeiten warten damit
unsere Menschen zurückkommen und ich bin
sicher
dass Menschen in Deutschland sensibel
sind und Sie können diese Belastung
aushandeln
ist dann können unsere Menschen auch
zurückkommen dann wird das ja auch für
Menschen in Deutschland leichter sein
talking about the war and when it good
and über den Krieg spricht und wenn er
enden könnte was ist ihre Hoffnung wann
wird der Krieg aufhören dieses Jahr wann
wird es soweit sein
wir wollen alle dass der Krieg
vielleicht schon gestern zu Ende ist
aber jetzt und Prognosen zu treffen das
können wir nicht tun das ist alles
umsonst
wir sehen wir stark
die Unterstützung ist
diese Hilfe die wir jetzt bekommen haben
früher bekommen hätten in dem Ausmaß in
dem wir es gebraucht hätte dann wäre es
alles viel schneller gegangen deshalb
wissen wir dass wir jetzt vorne ganzen
Welt sehr stark abhängig
und das betrifft auch das Ende des
Krieges in der ersten Linie wir werden
erschaffen aber diese Zeit
wie lange es noch dauert hängt davon ab
wie schnell wir die Unterstützung
bekommen das sind make you angry
sometimes macht es sie manchmal sauer
wenn sie zurückdenken dass die Hilfe
nicht so schnell kamen wie es wie sie es
sich erhofft haben
vielleicht bringt es nicht
jetzt zu kritisieren wozu natürlich
wenn du die Opfer siehst die ist
vielleicht nicht Gerber waren wir
rechtzeitig die Unterstützung bekommen
hatte dann
gibt es Verzweiflung weil du nichts mehr
tun kannst es gibt aber nur Hoffnung
dass die Welt noch aktive Handeln wird
wir haben keine Zeit mehr Angst zu haben
dann am Anfang hatten wir Angst dass der
Angreifer wütend wird oder das Wehen
verärgern aber jetzt kann es nicht
schlimmer sein es gibt keinen Grund mehr
Angst zu haben deshalb
weiß ich dass die
Opfer halten vermeiden können
und wenn wir auch daran denken nach
welchen Ereignissen gibt es größer
Unterstützung das erste Mal nach Butcher
nach den letzten Montag gab es noch eine
starke Welle ich möchte nicht
das wie eine Tragödie nach der anderen
haben damit wie stärkere Unterstützung
bekommen es ist ungerecht wir können
nicht darauf warten
bis nächster Tragödien geschieht damit
die Welt uns mehr unterstützt
welche Fragen stellen ihre Kinder zum
Krieg gibt es eine die sie immer stellen
das ist die gleiche Frage die sie mir
gerade gefragt haben
wann wird das zu Ende sein es ist eine
philosophische Frage keine hat die
Antwort darauf leider
auch wenn heute ein schrecklicher Tag
war mit kamikazedonen Menschen sind
gestorben wenn Sie nach Hause kommen
können Sie noch lachen und Witze machen
oder ist das nicht mehr möglich
vielleicht sollte man kurz erwähnen dass
sie früher Comedy gemacht haben genauso
wie ihr Mann gibt es noch Zeit für Witze
your husband so
ist das
ich habe das Gefühl dass Lachen
ist eine
Eigenschaft der Menschen in Ukraine wir
finden immer etwas wo du bei wir lachen
können und Sie sehen wie viele MamS
jeden Tag ausgedacht werden es ist
vielleicht ein schwarzer Humor aber es
der Humor der uns hilft durchzuhalten
wir haben unsere
Dichterin lässt der Ukraine sie hat
gesagt um nicht zu weinen habe ich
gelacht es gibt immer Möglichkeit zu
lächeln
auch darüber dass du dich erschrocken
hast
du etwas vergessen hast es gibt eine
komische Situation
aber das zeigt gut was bei uns so
geschieht neulich war ich in Polen und
habe eine ukrainische Schule besucht
eine wunderbare Schule wunderbare Lehre
wunderbare Kinder
wir haben miteinander gesprochen
und ich habe fast eine Frage gestellt
doch rechtzeitig mich zurückgehalten wo
ist der Luftschutzraum wollte ich fragen
ich habe dann begriffen dass ich nicht
den Ukraine bin und hier muss ich diese
Frage nicht stellen
unsere lebensparaktiven hat sich
verändert und weil ich in der Ukraine
die Schule besuche dann gehe ich als
erstes in den bombenschutz Raum und das
gleiche ist mir in Polen passiert ich
habe selbst über mich selbst gelacht
und ich weiß dass es vielleicht nicht
sehr lustig
aber es ist trotzdem
ich könnte über mich lachen denn ich bin
so einem Mensch geworden der
Luftschutzräume kontrolliert
zum Beispiel nach Amerika haben dort die
First Lady chill Biden getroffen sie
waren bei der Beerdigung der Queen wie
ist das für Sie die wichtigsten
Politiker der Welt zu treffen und gibt
es jemand den sie besonders schätzen
wir können keine Zeit vergeuden wir
müssen diese Möglichkeiten nutzen
und diese Zeit in der wir offen und
ehrlich mit Menschen kommunizieren die
in der Welt wichtige Entscheidungen
treffen können ich nutze diese
Möglichkeit und ich freue mich über
diese Möglichkeit
während der Beerdigung der Queen in
London gab es viele treffen
es ist eine große Ehre dass die
Vertreter aus der Ukraine
eingeladen wurden
und diese Zeremonie
dann es war eine Versammlung der
wichtigsten Menschen in der Welt und wir
waren unter ihnen
in den zwei Tagen gab es sehr viele
wichtige Grafen und ich hoffe sehr dass
manche trafen dann Folgetreffen haben
und dass wir Vereinbarungen treffen die
für die Ukraine gut sind mit Frauen
beide haben wir sehr gute Beziehungen
die haben schon so oft miteinander
gesprochen
das ist uns erlaubt
direkt ein Gespräch zu beginnen
und zwar ein praktischer
Gespräch ohne Förmlichkeiten am Anfang
ist ja wohl message you have gibt es
eine Nachricht die sie an die deutschen
richten wollen was muss ich ihrer
Meinung nach verändern oder was sollte
Deutschland für die Ukraine tun
[Musik]
ich denke ich habe heute bereits gesagt
keine Angst haben es ist schon zu spät
Angst zu haben
die Hilfe für die Ukraine bedeutet heute
Hilfe für sich selbst
denn dieser Krieg wird nicht ändern bis
der aggresso nicht versteht dass er
halt machen muss jemand muss ihn stoppen
wir müssen das zusammen tun
leider einzeln
kann man diesen Prozess
nicht durchgehen aber wenn wir es
zulassen ich glaube nicht daran aber
wenn es Ihnen gelingt
einige Ziele zu erreichen bedeutet das
dass wir alle zusammen verlieren
dass wir alle zusammen begreifen
wie in einer Welt leben werden in der
der aggresso bestimmt wie die Welt zu
sein scheint muss wann er Möglichkeit
hat finanzielle militärische politische
bitte alles tun was er will deshalb
möchte ich den Menschen in Deutschland
sagen es ist auch eure Krieg
thank you very much Dankeschön für das
Interview danke
[Musik]